welcome back to las vegas now you can
celebrate memorial day and honor our
heroes with the rotary club of green
valley the sponsors of this next segment
delinda crampton is here with all the
details for their third annual field of
honor and last time we interviewed you i
think you were outside in front of
hughes house
it's nice to have you it's nice to be in
the studio so introduce everybody who
doesn't who isn't aware just reintroduce
us to the field of honor right field of
honor this is our third annual one and
we will have 1 000 full-size u.s flags
flying at cornerstone park in henderson
right next to the lake it is it's
compelling it's stunning it's touching
it's moving
at night the flags are all lit up it's
incredible and then we also will have
besides the flags all weekend we'll have
a series of programs throughout the
weekend as well perfect and each program
will be different on each day absolutely
so let's start with day one okay so we
have two programs one is saturday
evening the other is the morning of
memorial day the saturday evening one is
honoring our first responders october 1
victims the soar award recipients which
are first responders here in town
and we're going to have some incredible
speakers some incredible musicians
award-winning musicians
some of the speakers
let's see on the the saturday evening
program we've got a cop that was at
october 1 with his daughter for the
concert people get shot he goes and
starts rescuing them halfway to the
hospital he gets the call that his
daughter's been shot as well in the back
and he has to make that difficult
decision what do i do rescues them goes
back and gets his daughter um
and then we also have a program on
memorial day at 9 00 a.m and that one is
honoring our military and we've got a
veteran who was a recipient of a homes
for heroes home he lost both his legs
was having trouble navigating his house
and this is a guy that was a race car
driver a professional golfer
he's a runner and just what he's done
with his life uh he's got a great story
that he's going to tell as well wow
that's incredible it's i love that
you're bringing in october one as well
to tie in the entire memorial heroes um
and obviously you can go and see and
enjoy the field of honor but you can
also be a part of it by purchasing a
flag yourself tell everybody about that
absolutely so the flag is forty dollars
it will have a tag on it and you can put
the name of the person who's being
honored why you're honoring them it
could be anyone it could be it doesn't
have to be military or first responder
it could be a hero in your life it could
be your mother or father and then after
the event you get to keep the flag if
you want that's beautiful thank you so
much to linda for what you and the
rotary club are doing for the community
i love that it's honoring all heroes yes
yes and we have so many heroes in our
lives absolutely especially in this
community so thank you to the rotary
club of green valley for sponsoring this
segment field of honor is may 27th
through the 30th at cornerstone park in
henderson for more information all you
got to do is visit green
greenvalleyrotary.org we'll be right
back